today on the mat wall show the left
wants us to forgive and forget about the
Tyranny they inflicted on US during
covet but I'll explain why we can't do
that also new documents reveal how the
government has been using big Tech to
squash the First Amendment the Supreme
Court possibly prepares to ban systemic
anti-white racism and college admissions
the government begins its UFO cover-up
and a woman on Tick Tock explains why
white people are morally obligated to
refrain from watching the New Black
Panther film I'm already one step ahead
of her on that all of that and more
today on the Matt Walsh show
foreign
[Music]
holiday season is rapidly approaching
and if there's one thing I love more
than spending the holidays with my
family it's spending the holidays with
my family while eating delicious meat
from good ranchers not only is good
ranchers meet Superior in quality but
also it's incredibly cost efficient as
well while grocery store meat prices are
on the rise good ranchers is dedicated
to helping you save as much as possible
so if you subscribe to good ranchers
today you can lock in your price and
avoid those insanely high prices at the
grocery store plus it's a special gift
for my listeners this holiday season
good ranchers is giving away two Black
Angus New York strip steaks free with
your order there are two 12-ounce
Steakhouse quality cuts a 70 value you
get it for free you don't want to miss
out on that Black Angus tastes better
and is more tender than other beef
that's attributed to the meats marbling
and marbled meat
the fat is distributed thinly and evenly
which is why you get that consistent
flavor plus the Black Angus from good
ranchers is hand cut and trimmed by
expert butchers so you know every piece
is going to be Exquisite so go to
goodranchors.com Walsh use code walls to
check out for this special offer that's
goodrancers.com Walsh for two Black
Angus New York strip steaks free with
your order good ranchers American Meat
delivered
you know I have to say this article in
the Atlantic is a little bit bewildering
to read I'm used to seeing the left
silence sensor defame threatened
blackmail their opponents these are all
tactics that we've grown familiar with
but asking for forgiveness now that is a
unique strategy though you don't have to
read very far to discover that this is
not a humble self-aware apology rather
the case is made that we should forgive
and forget while skipping over the
apology and the accountability steps
entirely is the demand for amnesty
um as it's called the author of The
Viral article Emily Oster
urges exactly that in the headline the
headline is in this article which has
gone viral let's declare a pandemic
amnesty we need to forgive one another
for what we did and said when we were in
the dark about covid
she begins in April 2020 with nothing
else to do my family took an enormous
number of hikes we all wore cloth masks
that I made myself we had a family hand
signal which uh the person in the front
would use if someone was approaching on
the trail and we needed to put our masks
on once when another child got too close
to my then four-year-old son on a bridge
he yelled out social distancing these
precautions were totally misguided in
April 2020 no one got the coronavirus
from passing somebody else hiking
outdoor transmission was vanishingly
rare our cloth masks made out of old
bandanas who wouldn't have done anything
anyway but the thing is we didn't know
yes but we did know Emily there are a
few things about Kobe that we knew
virtually from the very first moment one
is that there is not a high risk of
transmission outside the other is that
the virus particles are much smaller
than the pores on a cloth mask and we
knew both of those things because that's
what the data showed and also because
they were a matter of basic common sense
but there's more to say here uh we'll
allow Emily to flesh out her case though
she continues I've been reflecting on
this lack of knowledge thanks to a class
I'm co-teaching at Brown University on
covid we spent several lectures reliving
the first years of the pandemic
discussing the many important choices we
had to make under conditions of
tremendous uncertainty some of these
choices turned out better than others to
take an example close to my own work
there is an emerging if not Universal
consensus that schools in the U.S were
closed for too long the health risks of
in-school spread were relatively low
whereas the cost to students well-being
and educational progress were high the
latest figures on learning loss are
alarming but in spring and summer 2020
we had only glimmers of information
reasonable people people who cared about
children and teachers advocated on both
sides of the reopening debate another
example when the vaccines came out we
lacked definitive data on the relative
efficacies of the Johnson Johnson shot
versus the MRNA options from Pfizer and
moderna the MRI n a vaccines have one
out but at time many people in public
health were either neutral or expressed
a J and J preference this misstep wasn't
nefarious it was the result of
uncertainty
now she continually Retreats behind this
uncertainty line painting the two years
of coveted tyranny as a simple
misunderstanding driven by well-meaning
benevolent actors who were just doing
their best
she says quote most errors were made by
people who were working in Earnest for
the good of society given the amount of
uncertainty almost every position was
taken on every topic and on every topic
someone was eventually proved right and
someone else was proved wrong in some
instances the right people were right
for the wrong reasons in other instances
they had a prescient understanding of
the available information the people who
got it right for whatever reason may
want to gloat those who got it wrong for
whatever reason may feel defensive and
retrench into a position that doesn't
Accord with the facts all of this
gloating and defensiveness continues to
gobble up a lot of social energy and to
drive the culture wars especially on the
internet these discussions are heated
unpleasant and ultimately unproductive
in the face of so much uncertainty
getting something right had a hefty
element of luck and similarly getting
something wrong wasn't a moral failing
treating pandemic choices as a scorecard
on which some people racked up more
points than others is preventing us from
moving forward
yes moving forward is the aim she says
we must pick up the pieces
and move on together
United and happy into the sunset that's
how she wraps the piece up she says
moving on is crucial now because the
pandemic created many problems and we
still need to solve student test scores
have shown historical declines more so
in math and in reading and more so for
students who are disadvantaged at the
start we need to collect data experiment
then invest is high dosage tutoring more
or less cost effective than extended
school years we have some states for
have why have some states recovered
faster than others we should focus on
questions like these because answering
them is how we will help our children
recover the standard saying is that
those who forget history are doomed to
repeat it but dwelling on the mistakes
of History can lead to a repetitive Doom
loop as well let's acknowledge that we
made complicated choices in the face of
deep uncertainty and then try to work
together to build back and move forward
build back better some might even say
so Emily is um echoing here an
increasingly popular sentiment on the
left
they know they can't defend their
response to covid on the merits they
know that even the people who were most
compliant and obedient during the
coveted years
have now woken up from their stupors and
are looking back on all of it the way
that a guy with a hangover might look
back on the previous night spent binge
drinking
except that they were binging on fear
and panic and now the well has dried up
and they can see clearly what they
couldn't see before
now the left assumed and on this I
actually I I agreed with them and I
assumed too
that even after the mandates went away
many people would continue wearing the
masks and keeping up with the social
distancing routine and living in a state
of reflexive coveted Panic perpetually
forever Maybe
you know I thought that would happen I
was afraid that would happen
that's not what happened the mandates
were dropped and almost every
every person dropped the masks with them
you know most people aren't going in for
booster shots
I've traveled all over the country over
the past year just as I was traveling
all over the country at the height of
the covet panic and I can tell you that
even in the most liberal areas The Mask
wearers are now weirdos they're outliers
every plane has maybe one or two of them
a busy restaurant and a left-leaning
metro area might have one group come in
wearing the mask only to take it off at
the table of course continuing to
perform the pandemic Hokey Pokey dance
that never made any sense to begin with
but even those brain damage folks you
know they're not requesting a plastic
barrier be put up between themselves and
the other tables
some things are too absurd even for them
at this point
so my point is that
this is the only reason why we're
hearing about amnesty and forgiveness
it's only because the left discovered
that most people
never really bought into it they didn't
believe it
they just did what they were told
because they were afraid of the
consequences which is a problem in and
of itself but that's what was happening
the mental conditioning did not settle
in nearly to the extent that the left
had hoped and assumed and now they're
worried about the political consequences
so they're shrugging their shoulders and
saying that was weird guys right what do
you say we forget about all that stuff
and just move on
but we can't
we can't forgive
we can't forget
we can't have mercy on the coveted
tyrants
and here's why
first of all they didn't close down the
schools and force masking on everyone in
vaccines and take away people's
livelihoods and jobs and shut down
society and wage war on our civil
liberties all because they lacked
information
even if they did
that would be no excuse
because this is America you cannot say
to Americans we don't really know what's
going to what's going on or if this will
help but we're gonna ruin your lives and
take away your fundamental freedoms
anyway just in case
that is not an acceptable line of
reasoning in this country not even close
but that's also not the line of
reasoning they used despite actually
knowing most of what the writer says
they didn't know they violently and
forcefully imposed the opposite reality
or attempted to
I mean it wasn't as though the coveted
Panic Peddlers were simply offering one
perspective one opinion
they weren't saying you know this is
that this is how we feel about it guys
but yeah you do what you want to do
we don't really know
no they said that you're not allowed to
have any opinion or perspective but
theirs
they had people who disagreed with them
de-platformed and silenced
that's one of the reasons why this
continued for so long is because people
who had the opposite Viewpoint were
driven away
they sought to make it illegal to voice
an alternative point of view
if they didn't know if they didn't have
the information that makes this
tyrannical approach less justifiable not
more
but again they did know
they knew the opposite of what they
claimed they knew it because I knew it
and you knew it
and many of us were saying this in April
or May of 2020
shouldn't shut down the schools these
masks aren't doing anything you know you
don't need to be worried about uh
shutting down parks and beaches makes no
sense because if anything you want
people to be outside in the sun when a
virus is going around
many of us were saying that practically
from the beginning
we were saying that you know March April
May
they started saying it last week
how did we know it if our Public Health
authorities so-called did not
did we have access to information that
was unavailable to them
I mean the claim is absurd
now the point here is not to gloat
honestly I'm not much in the mood for
gloating after what they did and what
they took from us
children committed suicide elderly
people died alone in nursing homes
many businesses went under people people
lost everything gloat
no no we want Justice we want
accountability we want to set an example
so that they won't try this again move
on I'll move on after there have been
military tribunals
I'll move on when fauci and his comrades
are tried and convicted for crimes
against humanity and given the maximum
penalty for it
that's when we can move on
and not before it
here's an idea if you want to practice
forgiveness if you want to let people
move on from past mistakes
why not tell that to the cancel culture
vultures who spend their time digging
through comments people made uh have
made or made in the distant past and
then using those as a pretense for
destroying their lives in the present
I mean there is a lack of forgiveness in
our society but that's where it can be
felt
somebody expresses an opinion or makes a
joke and suddenly their persona non
grata they're disgraced ostracized
call for forgiveness there
that's what we needed
but the tyrants who took advantage of a
virus and used it as an opportunity to
seize control and wield power
no they don't deserve to be forgiven
they deserve to be punished
and and that's what we should do
now let's get to our five headlines
now the left is losing their faith but
we are not and a core part of that faith
is prayer I talk a lot about stressful
things all day and you might feel a
little bit overwhelmed with where the
country is going but I've got good news
for you hallow can help you find some
peace and hope throughout the day rooted
not in the government or in institutions
but in God hallow has over five thousand
audio guided prayers meditations and
peaceful Christian music including the
rosary with Bishop Baron and Mark
Wahlberg Bible bedtime stories with
Jonas Jonathan Rooney who plays a Jesus
in The Chosen prayers for kids so we
aren't raising another generation of
crazies and so much more Hello helps you
better daily routine and a habit of
prayer it helps me to pray meditate and
sleep better throughout the day and um
well not sleeping throughout the day I
don't sleep but you know I don't even
sleep at night most time anyway it's a
huge part of my daily routine get an
exclusive three-month trial at hallow
dot com slash Matt Walsh that's
hollow.com Matt Walsh reclaim your piece
in this crazy world make sure that you
download hello today
all right so uh
hopefully you had a good Halloween my
kids enjoyed trick-or-treating last
night they enjoyed it even though nobody
understood their costumes you know my
kids are the weird ones who always
choose these obscure costumes on
Halloween at least my older two do so
they they um
they never liked they're never
superheroes or Disney characters
whatever this year they they uh the
twins went as characters from Jurassic
World
which is the reboot Jurassic Park
franchise so they went as reboot
Jurassic Park characters
and I tried to tell them that like no
one is going to know who you are you're
just wearing a vest no one's going to
know where that's from uh the costume is
way too specific at Halloween so I've
been telling them for nine years
Halloween you play the hits okay you
play the stick with the classics that's
what you do on Halloween but um they
don't it doesn't sink and so every year
my kids are like I want to go as a car
salesman just what you could be a
werewolf or Spider-Man or something the
other thing that's guaranteed to happen
on on Halloween if you have a toddler is
that and this is getting this is just
every single year there's going to be a
last minute wardrobe change
um or else she'll refuse out of nowhere
to wear any costume at all without
without any explanation just like super
excited about a costume and then the day
comes the Night Comes I don't want to
wear that no explanation at all can't
reason it out can't can't tell you why
so our toddler um
was supposed to be the The Little
Mermaid for for Halloween and was very
excited about it
and then at the last minute says you
don't want to be a little mermaid
anymore maybe because she knows that
little the little mermaid is black now
and she doesn't want to culturally
appropriate that could be it so I try to
be sensitive to it and she decided she
wanted to be a dinosaur I guess in
keeping with the Jurassic World theme
and uh and my wife had a dinosaur
costume just on hand to give her because
my wife is prepared for all holiday
related emergencies and she was prepared
for that one so we went out
and it was good it rained you know uh it
started raining and and uh the kids at a
certain point were just like they wanted
to stop and my wife was the one pushing
everyone to keep going she said no we
just do a couple more houses and it's
pouring rain and all the kids are
complaining and I'm complaining now it's
my wife and I told her I said I could
if you I can buy you candy if you want I
get what candy do you want we could go
to Walgreens on the way back and I'll
buy it for you this is no we don't need
to do this
so they did uh they made out pretty well
and I and I did explain
to my kids before they went to bed I you
know because they they had their their
their Hall and their bags and I
explained to them this really
interesting scientific phenomenon where
bags of candy will actually they'll kind
of settle and condense overnight
um so that in the morning they'll be
much lighter and there will appear to be
less candy than there was when they went
to bed it's a very interesting
uh scientific event that occurs but you
gotta trust the science
and just don't worry about it
my uh my daughter was skeptical but the
other kids just just bought it all right
we'll start with this from the daily
wire it says hundreds of internal
documents exposed top U.S government
agencies working closely with social
media companies like Facebook and
Twitter to censor American freedom of
speech under the guise of fighting
disinformation over several years as
obtained and reported by The Intercept
the intercepts investigative journalist
Lee Fang broke the story on Monday
confirming what Americans have feared in
the current age of censorship that only
authoritarian regimes could only uh
could dream of an acting in a nation
founded on the unabridged right to
freedom of speech by Monday night Fang
appeared on Tucker Carlson tonight to
discuss the bombshell report
thankful Carson quote we looked at
hundreds of documents that paint a vivid
picture of the FBI the Department of
Homeland Security closely collaborating
with the top social media platforms
Twitter and Facebook to censor various
forms of content under the banner of
fighting disinformation thanks to the
story shows a very cozy relationship
between the government alphabet agencies
like the FBI and DHS and Tech Giants
where they held monthly meetings as
recently as August and exchanged emails
and texts to shape online discourse one
of those cozy relationships highlighted
in the report uh shows a text from
earlier this year between former DHS
official and current Microsoft executive
Matt Masterson and Jen easterly a DHS
director saying the government needs to
get the private sector needs to get more
comfortable with the government
exactly what it means platforms have to
get comfortable with the government okay
it's really it's interesting how
hesitant they remain
you need to get comfortable with the
government
is what they were saying so this was and
you could look at the report from the
intercept and it goes into Lee Fang's
report uh this is real
you know there are some people out there
doing real journalism here's one example
and uh what it shows is this end run
that the government was performing uh to
get around the first amendment and just
going right to the big tech companies
and saying we need to be you need to get
comfortable with us and we're going to
be policing disinformation this is why
they're so paranoid about Elon Musk
taking over obviously this is this is
actually what they're worried about
um they're worried that this you know
not only will this come to an end and
they're not going to con not gonna be
able to control the public discourse
anymore but also the people working at
these platforms you know they just never
imagined like at Twitter
they never imagined
that someone who is not a comrade
someone who is not a an ideological
compatriot would one day run the company
it just it never
occurred to them
which is why these emails and text
messages are coming out now they're very
explicit
they're putting all the stuff in writing
just because they figured like this is
Twitter this is big Tech it's always
going to be in our hands and by hour I
mean on the left
the idea that someone else would come in
who is not who has not sworn ideological
allegiance to them was unthinkable
but that's what happened
um which isn't even to say that Elon
Musk is a conservative because I don't
think he is and he doesn't claim to be
he's just not a died in the wall leftist
he's not that
and so we're going to find out a lot
more about
this sort of thing
um
you know this is this is another another
one of the reasons why you can you
really can't even call these big tech
companies private companies they're
really not
they are private in name only maybe
um but they're but they're not actually
these are quasi-government institutions
now that's good looks like that's going
to change with Twitter
I hope it changes
but up until now this is what it was you
know these are quasi-government
institutions they work closely with the
government
they've gotten comfortable with the
government
and uh and they they work to advance and
they share you know they they share an
agenda they share an objective
um and so they're working together
and and the the it's increasingly
difficult to distinguish between the two
and of course it all it should also go
without saying that
policing disinformation or
misinformation this is not the purview
of the government
uh now I understand why the government
would want it to be in their purview
because we live in the information age
uh information is everything and there's
there's
and everywhere information is everywhere
we're all absorbing information
uh at a you know historically
unprecedented rate every single day
like we we encounter more information in
a single day than people prior to the
Modern Age would have encountered in a
lifetime
and so if you control the flow and
spread of information then you control
everything and control Society
you control what people think
I mean this is this is for them this is
much better than oh yeah it's one thing
to to pass laws
like we talked about in the opening
they passed laws and they passed
mandates and they were able to force
compliance much more than they should
have been able to do
but they didn't they didn't change what
people believed
because as soon as the Mandate went away
people took the masculine the most
revealing thing was on the planes
because the planes were the were some of
the only hole were among the last of the
holdouts
where you still had to wear a mask on a
plane up until you know recently
and everybody was 100 compliant on the
planes and in airports even though in
the airports he didn't have to be
now on the plane I you know I always
tested it I would take the mask off for
as long as I get away with but on a
plane you couldn't get away with it for
very long in an airport though this is
all through covid I never wore a mask in
the airport because there was no you
know nobody would there really wasn't
once you got through TSA
um there wasn't any Central sort of
authority figure that could tell you to
put it on maybe you passed by a gate
agent who would say put your mask on I
just ignore him and walk by what are
they gonna do call TSA they never did
um but most people didn't even test it
they just put the mask on they did as
they were told however
mask mandate goes away and immediately
everyone takes the mask off
it's like 99.9 of the people take the
mask off with it with just a few
outliers right
well that shows that they were able to
control Behavior
but they were not able to control in
this case they were today they were not
able to control the way people think to
the extent that they wanted
I think the the government's learning a
lesson from that the regime is learning
a lesson
exactly the wrong lesson but they're
learning a lesson what they're learning
is that yeah we could pass laws we could
pass mandates we can force people at
gunpoint to do things
but it's much more valuable if you can
control how people think
and what they believe
because then they'll do your bidding
without you even telling them they have
to
and then you can claim that it's not
tyranny that it's not oppression because
there is there's no law saying people
have to do this they're just doing it
well they're doing it because you've
manipulated them at the deepest level
and that's what this is all about
obviously
all right NBC has this report it says um
conservative Supreme Court Justices
indicated on Monday that they are
willing to end the explicit
consideration of race and college
admissions as they weigh cases
challenging affirmative action policies
at the University of North Carolina and
Harvard University members of the
Court's conservative majority question
the legal rationale for allowing the
practice improved to what extent
colleges and universities could enact
new race neutral admissions policies
aimed at improving racial diversity some
justices however indicated that they
would be willing to allow applicants to
discuss their racial identities in some
form as part of essays touching upon
their experiences such as examples of
overcoming discrimination liberal
Justice who are in the minority defended
the use of race and Emissions citing the
importance of diversity on campus and
the difficulty of achieving it
without any consideration of race
affirmative action introduced to redress
historic discrimination has been a
contentious issue for years yada yada
but it's looking now based on based on
these oral arguments which can be
deceptive but based on those it looks
like
um this could be
yeah affirmative action in the college
administ Administration admissions game
could be going the way of Roe v Wade
a few points about this
first
obviously you cannot prevent or heal
racial discrimination
by committing it
um the most you can do is swap one type
for another that's the most you could
possibly do
so it's just like if you're worried
about
um
to use a phishing analogy if you're
worried about a an invasive predatory
species of fish in an ecosystem
and and so in order to address that
problem you release a different invasive
predatory fish into the ecosystem to eat
that one
well now you've just you've just swapped
out one invasive species for another you
haven't gotten rid of the problem
you've just created a different problem
to take its place now you might say that
well this other fish is uh you know if
we have to have one we'd rather have
this other predatory invasive species
but but that is what the argument you're
making you're not getting rid of it
you're just you're just you're you're
replacing it with a different version
that you find to be
um less threatening
but then in reality of course what's
most likely going to happen is uh that
you don't just replace one species of
another now you end up with both
actually that's probably what's going to
happen
and that's what they're trying to do
here let's let's get rid of the systemic
um racism against
racial minorities by replacing it with a
mandatory
systemic racism against white people
and and here's the other thing
if if it worked
okay
if it actually if the plan actually
worked
to
Institute racial discrimination against
whites in order to prevent racial
discrimination or to get rid of racial
discrimination against blacks then it
shouldn't be needed anymore
uh affirmative action policies have been
in place for decades
so even by their own logic
let's let's just say that yeah there was
a this is there's systemic racism in the
University system and so they needed to
put these affirmative action policies in
place to get rid of it
okay well it's been decades now
if you're telling me that it's still
needed
that would seem to indicate that it's
not working to solve the problem that
you're trying to solve
but this is the built-in advantage of
the systemic racism Theory
it's unfalsifiable
which means that it is false that's the
thing about unfalsifiable Theory an
unfalcified viable theory that they're
always false they're always illegitimate
because if there's nothing that could
happen if there's no evidence that could
possibly be presented that would prove
your theory false
that means that your theory exists
independent of the evidence which means
it is a bad Theory
if your theory is based on the evidence
that you have available then you should
be able to tell us what sort of evidence
could be presented that would make you
go okay well I'm wrong about this or the
facts have changed and this is no longer
uh the case anymore
for systemic racism the purveyors of
this Theory have made it clear that
nothing can ever happen
that will prove to them that it doesn't
exist
it's impossible to solve the problem so
you can have affirmative action for 40
or 50 years you can elect the black
president you can you can you can have
all these different policies putting
minorities into positions of leadership
you can have racial minorities running
many of the major cities all across the
country you can do all of this and much
more
and it's it's done according to then
them absolutely nothing to solve the
problem problem still exists in fact if
anything it's it's worse now than it's
ever been if you listen to them
so that means either that the entire
theory is bunk
unfalsifiable exists apart from the
evidence or
um that's um
what they're doing just isn't working
you know or a combination of the two
and there's also this basic idea that um
diversity is desirable for its own sake
because that's what the liberal Justice
is
are really saying so they're not even so
much saying that we still have this
embedded
uh anti-black systemic racism in the
University system
they might think that but they're not
that's not really the argument
the argument is just that we need to
have racial diversity it's good for its
own sake and the only way to get it
is to give racial minorities an embedded
advantage and to and to disadvantage uh
White applicants and also Asian
applicants
Justice Thomas he tried to strike at
this idea in his line of questioning I
thought that this was a pretty good
listen to this
I've heard the word uh diversity quite a
few times and I don't have a clue what
it means
uh it seems to mean everything for
everyone
uh the and I'd like you first you did
give some examples in your opening
remarks
but I'd like you to give us a specific
definition of diversity in the context
of the University of North Carolina
and I'd also like you to give us a a
clear idea of exactly
what the educational benefits of
diversity at the University of North
Carolina
would be
yes your honor so first we Define
diversity the way this court has in its
Court's precedence which means a broadly
diverse set of criteria that extends to
all different backgrounds and
perspectives and not solely limited to
race and there's a factual finding in
this record pet app 113 that there are
many different diversity factors that
are considered as a greater factor in
our admissions process than race
uh diversity of they always throw that
in there well we also take into account
diversity of perspectives
yeah you take it into account so that
you can exclude it because that's the
last thing that you want on the college
campus
on the modern college campus that's the
last thing they want is a diversity of
perspectives
and but that is you know there are
I don't think diversity for its own sake
should ever be just the objective it
should it should always be a byproduct
so in the case of college admissions
the objective is to admit
as many qualified applicants as you can
and to do so on the basis of Merit to to
admit the most qualified applicants
that should be the objective
diversity is not the objective it's a
byproduct
it could be a happy byproduct
but even then the the the most
advantageous or the most desirable
diversity byproducts
it's not a diversity of skin tones and
skin pigmentation
then it does go to a diversity of
perspectives people who think
differently about things like that's
that's where you get the the richness of
the educational environment and that's
where people are gonna you know that's
where people can hone their ideas by you
know having debate and discussion like
that's that is the kind of diversity
that you do want again though but as a
byproduct even then not as the objective
yeah
so they're taking
the the less important forms of
diversity the more meaningless sort of
forms of diversity
having a room full of people that all
have different shades and and skin tones
like that's
uh and they're not only making that the
most important form of diversity but
they're making that the objective rather
than the byproduct which is what it's
supposed to be
speaking of diversity hires Al Sharpton
apparently still
exists and has a show in MSNBC uh listen
to them here he's supposed to be
interviewing Kathy halkuel of uh of the
governor of New York
um who herself is essentially diversity
higher as well she's she has never been
elected to anything by the way she's
never been elected to anything she's
just she's just been writing coattails
all the way up to the top all the way up
to the governor Mansion but this is
supposed to be an interview questioning
her but really this is him coaching her
and giving her some talking points
listen to this
I don't think anyone has been stronger
in many states on on dealing with gun
control and working with communities I
remember when you were lieutenant
governor you used to show up everywhere
uh what where the anti-crime folks so I
mean is this just a distorted way of
campaigning I mean what do you read into
this heaven now these are Master
manipulators they have this conspiracy
going all across America to try and
convince people that in Democratic
states they're not as safe well guess
what they're also not only election
deniers they're data deniers the data
shows that shootings and murders are
down in our state by 15 percent even in
New York City down 20 percent on Long
Island really zeldin comes from and it's
a it's a depth it's the Republican
states where they have almost no
restrictions on guns because of the
abundance of guns people are killing
each other with more frequency the safer
places are the Democratic states
foreign
first of all uh
words have meaning I have to continually
insist I have to insist on this that
words have meaning and the word
conspiracy has a meaning
okay and so saying even if you're wrong
saying that uh blue democrat-run cities
are not safe that's not a conspiracy
theory that's just uh that's just a a
claim about reality whether you're right
or wrong it's just it's a claim it's not
a conspiracy theory
um
now
you you could go further and theorize
about some conspiracies that are
happening there which are not really
theories at all for example George Soros
um you know pouring money into these
races to elect
DA's who will not enforce the law sowing
chaos and Anarchy into our system and
into into the our communities
and yeah that's a I suppose you could
call that a conspiracy in effect but
it's not a theory it's like it is
actually happening
um
so that's the first thing and also the
way that they switch between state and
city oh the red states are more
dangerous
well if a red state is dangerous
uh it's because of the blue cities
within the red States
those are always going to be the most
dangerous areas
and that again is not a theory
yeah go ahead and look at the data
look at data in New York okay if you
want if you want data you want you want
you want uh you want to be data driven
here
look at crime and violence
in New York City under Rudy Giuliani
in the early 2000s
and then compare that
to crime and violence now
ever since far left Democrats took over
starting with um de Blasio and on Ford
if you really want if you really want
the data that's what you should be
looking at
all right
this is from uh oh I got to mention this
this is from the military times it says
Pentagon attributes UFO sightings to
spies and Airborne trash
that's no way to speak about aliens
intelligence officials are set to
deliver Congress a new report today this
was yesterday so they already delivered
it I guess on unexplained aerial
phenomenon better known as UFOs the
document from the office of the Director
of National Intelligence will provide an
update to a report the intelligence
agency made public in June June of 2021
which explored more than 140 incidents
of UAP encounters between
2004-2021. despite calls for greater
transparency from lawmakers and military
leaders it's not yet clear which
contents of the coming report will be
made public while it could offer more
detailed explanations into the surge of
recent sightings defense Department
officials are downplaying theories of
alien invasions and emphasizing ordinary
objects that they say are more likely to
blame
military officials stole the New York
Times that post uh that most resolved
UFO cases can be attributed to foreign
spies or Airborne trash
okay I want to know about the Airborne
trash so there's trash in the sky
speeding along at the speed of sound
changing directions mid-flight
where's this trash coming from
is it trash that the aliens have thrown
out of their UFOs
uh maybe they'll explain that how that
works exactly in May during congress's
first public UFO Hearing in more than 50
years Pentagon officials testified that
a video with mysterious glowing green
triangles actually displayed drones that
were shot through night vision lenses
sure in another video referred to as go
fast an unknown object appear to move at
incredible speed military officials
later debunked the video as an illusion
created by the angle of observation
against water oh come on
so where's the trash part of it are they
going to even explain in this article
how trash could
what is what's what is the trash doing
40 000 feet in the air and how is it
moving that way and what kind of trash
is this
are these plastic straws have the
plastic straw problem gotten that bad
that now they're they're whizzing
through the sky too
um
skimming ahead
no they don't revisit that if they don't
revisit and the article they never
explain they just ah it's probably
Airborne trash what do you mean Airborne
trash yeah just you know just trash
because sometimes
so you bring your uh
garbage cans out to the curb and then
you come in the morning you come out in
the morning and they're gone and you
think that like the trash man took them
away but sometimes they'll just they'll
fly up into the sky and you know and and
and freak out Navy Pilots it happens
sometimes I guess
this is ridiculous you know what this
makes me more convinced that you'll talk
about conspiracy theories okay here's
one this makes me more convinced than
ever
that aliens not only are real which is
which is just a fact but have been to
Earth because now there was a moment
I was actually I was less convinced back
when it seemed that the government was
being open about it and they started
talking about it and they said yeah
we'll talk about aliens and then I
thought well okay this is not they
wouldn't something's not right here but
now they're retrenching again and
they're and they're you know yeah we've
debunked it don't worry about it
never mind
that yeah they've explained the ones
that they can explain with normal you
know just in by pointing to normal
expected physical phenomena so they've
explained the ones that can be explained
okay I get that big big breaking news
there
but there's still The Lion's Share of
these sightings that have never been
explained
and those are the ones who are
interested in
and again I really want to understand
how Tre how you can blame this on trash
it's uh you know someone threw a Coke
can into the air and then the light
refracting from Jupiter and bouncing off
of the ocean created a
uh it's a a hallucination type effect
and this okay right
all right one other thing uh to play for
you before we get to the comment section
the New Black Panther film is coming out
soon uh this is uh you know the first
black panther was terrible I didn't see
it but I know that it's terrible because
it's a Marvel comic book movie
um and uh all Marvel comic book movies
are terrible as Martin Scorsese said
they're they're basically just theme
park rides except that they're boring
and repetitive theme park rides so
they're more like these are more they're
not theme park these are carnival rides
for children these are like the teacup
ride that goes around in circles that's
what all these movies are
um anyway so the New Black Panther is
coming out next week
but according to tick tock if you're
white
you better not be there on opening day
[Music]
this message is to all our would-be
accomplices and white allies
this message is to all the white people
who have BLM in their bio
if you really want to prove to black
people that you love us and you care
about us and you are down for the cause
do not go see that movie opening weekend
you buy your ticket you give it to a
black person or a black family who can't
afford to go and then you go sit at that
theater in front of the doors you make
sure that every black person in that
theater can enjoy that movie in peace
you make sure that you use your body to
block us from anybody who will be coming
in that theater to do us harm that is
your job
you can go see it on another weekend go
see it on the second or third weekend
but the first weekend that's for us to
do anything other than this is
anti-black
agreed you know I first of all let me
say if not seeing Black Panther on
opening night makes you Progressive and
anti-racist then uh call me ibrahamex
Walsh because I am I mean I'm
so Progressive that I will never watch
it at all I I would not want to take
that experience away from or impede in
any way on the experiences of black
Americans and so I will just never ever
watch it and uh that's what I'll do
um and uh no I mean as far as sitting in
front of the theater I don't think I'm
going to go to that extent but also it
gets confusing because what if I'm
sitting in front of the theater
protecting the theater from White
presence
how what what about a biracial person
who's trying to come watch it what do we
do
with him
do I say well you can watch it with one
eye open I mean so what do you do about
that
um
I I will be interested to see if any
white uh woke people
actually follow through on this to prove
their will credentials yet for me as
ludicrous as this all is
the bigger issue is just how this film
is treated like some sort of
sacred thing you know something of deep
significance
for the black community
Black Panther
and it just shows
a total lack of culture and I don't mean
a total lack of culture among black
people I mean lack of culture in America
I mean lack of American culture
uh it's like this anti-culture it's not
a culture
because this is these are for for all
communities the most important stories
our most cherished stories that we take
uh so seriously whether on racial
grounds or not they're superhero movies
they're these corporate things you know
corporate franchises Brands like this is
this is what we take seriously this is
our most sacred and art what we Revere
the most
our art is all a brand and that is a
that's a that is an anti-culture that's
not culture
so that's my takeaway from this
let's get to the comment section
[Music]
David says I disagree with you Matt I
like to work I want to work I find my
purpose in my work if I was on a
permanent vacation and a billionaire I
would be downright miserable and life
wouldn't be worth living the best days
of my life are the ones full of
adversity and I Collapse into bed dead
tired but with something accomplished if
I had to slop pigs for a living it would
still be worth it providing for my
family and a sense of purpose can't get
better than that
no I don't think we disagree I mean I I
basically agree that I think
well it's hard to say when you're not
when it's when you're not uh actually in
the position but um you know I'm not I
think the lottery right now is up to a
billion dollars the Powerball jackpot
I'm not gonna go play it because for one
thing it's I'm not gonna win but also
yeah I don't I don't know it I don't
actually desire that it's it does it
does seem rather depressing to just have
be given all of that money especially as
a young person it's like well what do
you do what are you working for for the
rest of your life
um once the thrill of having all that
money wears off and it's like well I
didn't earn this it was just given to me
and now there's uh by nothing to do but
this same time
when someone actually offers you the
check would you in reality turn it down
hard to say until you're in that
position but my point is no matter how
you feel about work
whether you want to work you don't want
to work
it almost doesn't really matter
because the point is that this is just
this that that this is life this is what
life is that life is work and you cannot
separate work from life
work comes in different forms you know
it doesn't mean that your life is a job
doesn't mean you know you could you
could do you could not have a job and
still be working
uh just as
people did for most of human history
they didn't have jobs the way that we
think of it in the Industrial Age but
they certainly were working
um and that is life and as I'm always
pointing out you know
if you try to to sever yourself from
work if you try to live a life apart
from work
you're not choosing some holier than
thou more kind of enlightened uh
approach
because your life still depends on work
it's just that other people are doing it
for you now you're depending on other
people to work for you whether it's your
parents because you're living in the
basement or it's the government it's the
taxpayers rather not the government it's
the taxpayers whatever it is you are now
depending on the work of others
while pretending that you're above above
it all you know that you're living this
enlightened life oh we don't work I'm
I'm too good for that
you know the people that are feeding you
and clothing you and putting a roof over
your head it's not too good for them
apparently
um
Eduardo says I wish I worked with Matt
and I could come to into work as a
watermelon and sit right across from him
for the whole day LOL
well that would that would be an issue
because I'm in my office and if you just
came there and sat in silence dressed as
a watermelon that you would be fired on
the spot I don't have the power to do it
but
I would anyway
um Chris says I'm convinced that Matt
Walsh's ad writers are trolling him yeah
you think so maybe just you just picked
up on that
uh
let's see
Lucy says I for sure made my own sexy
Matt Walsh costume posted my pick on the
Facebook sweet baby gang hahaha
well you're actually banned from the
show for that because to say sexy Matt
Walsh costume it makes it sound like
it's a variation of what a Matt Walsh
would normally be
so you're you know it's like it's like
you're whatever you're a a sexy uh
Frankenstein or something that's that's
what that's what I'm getting from so
it's that I take that as an insult
against me so you're back from the show
um
Anna says thank you for your contrarian
takes on children's stories I've always
felt that Snow White was the bad guy in
her story but I assume I don't have to
tell you why no you don't you're
preaching to the choir on that one I
mean this creepy Drifter is wandering
around in the woods and comes upon this
house and then just like walks in if I'm
remembering the Snow White story I
haven't seen in a long time but she just
walks in to a house and then starts
snooping around and then she and she
goes into the bedroom rearranges the
beds and falls asleep it takes a nap and
someone's house
what kind of psychopath breaks into
someone's house and takes a nap you hear
about cases like that like in San
Francisco and and in in cities where
homeless heroin addicts will will do
that
it's very disturbing to see trespassing
and burglary taken so lightly in a
children's story especially in light of
what happened at Nancy Pelosi's house so
it's just it's it's too soon and then
the dwarves come back and they're just
these hard-working Blue Collar guys
and they happen to be a foot and a half
tall and they think I think they're a
little bit mentally disabled and they
come in and they see this woman sleeping
in their bed and she's a giant compared
to them so they feel they have no choice
but to allow her to say to stay now
she's a squatter and it's like really is
basically kidnapping
and she's also a [ __ ] because the evil
witch comes along and the evil witch is
a has shape-shifting abilities she can
take any form she wants apparently and
she chooses to shapeshift into an even
more evil looking witch which doesn't
make any sense to me
she goes to well not Snow White's house
the house that she's taken over knocks
on the window and is like has an evil
laugh and just hands her an apple and
Snow White takes it and eats it who
some weird looking deformed
Old Woman Who literally has an evil
laugh knocks on your window and hands
you a fruit basket and without asking
any questions you just start eating from
it
and then she passes out and the the
dwarves for some reason had a glass
coffin
the size of Snow White ready to go so I
don't think there are any innocent
parties in this story at all there's a
lot of weird things happen they have
this coffin ready to go they don't even
check her to see if she's breathing they
just put her in the coffin they're gonna
bury her and then the prince comes along
he's introduced to the story we've never
seen this guy before and because he's
just wandering the woods and comes
everyone's just wandering in the woods
coming across this he walks up to this
woman who he thinks is dead
and kisses her on the lips can you
imagine going to a wake of someone you
don't know
and walking up to the corpse and kissing
it and everyone's looking at you like
who is that guy does he even know
and then she wakes up and supposed to be
happily ever the whole thing is just
bizarre it's very bizarre stuff there
are no good guys in that story at all
the corporate media agenda means that
the news is presented in a biased way
you know it I know it we all know it
thankfully there's a way to get the most
important news of the day without the
narrative and that's by listening to one
of the top news podcasts morning wire
new episodes are available every morning
seven days a week and they cover stories
other media Outlets won't touch and
every Sunday until the midterm elections
you can also tune into election wire for
in-depth uh coverage candidate
interviews and much more
it's the most important midterm
elections in recent history and uh we
it's not like we say that for every
election this is the most important and
you'll want to be informed you'll find
morning wire and election wire and Allen
daily wire plus Apple podcast Spotify or
wherever you listen to podcasts now
let's get to our daily cancellation
[Music]
you know Jeffrey Marsh is a name that
has probably come up with a daily
cancellation before he's a 45 year old
creep who's gained prominence in the
groomer community Through Tick Tock
videos promoting transgenderism to kids
now according to the bio on his website
his videos have received over 1 billion
views in total he goes on to Pat his
stats and his bio by claiming to be
quote the first non-binary public figure
to appear on National Television
of course non-binary simply means that
he's a dude who wears eye shadow and and
women's clothing and if you believe that
Jeffrey Marsh is the first guy to do
that on TV I would like to introduce you
to something called the 1980s where it
was quite common there's nothing bold or
pioneering about cross-dressing in fact
at this point it's much more unique for
a man to appear on television wearing
men's clothing if you really want to be
a trendsetter simply dare to be normal
in this Society one other possible note
of interest from Marsha's bio
it says quote Jeffrey has studied and
taught Zen for over 20 years their
rigorous training while living as a monk
at a Buddhist Monastery in California as
chronicled in his book How To Be You
resulted in Jeffrey receiving the status
of precepted facilitator in the Soto Zen
tradition of Buddhism the rank of
precepted facilitator is an elite
category and marks a Zen practitioner
trained to assist anyone towards
spiritual growth
so in keeping with his distinctive and
individual individualistic approach to
life Jeffrey Marsh calls himself a
Buddhist
just like literally every other liberal
white guy in California and by the way
at the risk of butchering Buddhist
teachings
um I don't pretend to be an expert on
the subject because I don't pretend to
be Buddhist unlike
Jeffrey Marsh
but I'm pretty sure that one of the
fundamental ideas in Buddhism is that
you're supposed to detach yourself from
desire
but the LGBT cult totally defines Itself
by its desires it teaches that life is
best lived in pursuit of what you desire
no matter what your desires might to be
might be this represents if anything a
kind of anti-budist philosophy it seems
to me
it's like that's the opposite of what
Buddhism is but I'll leave it to the
Buddhist to make that case
um today my concern is is one of the
most recent videos posted by this
non-binary Buddhist Zen cross-dressing
groomer monk in this video as he has in
so many other videos Marsh attempts to
definitively debunk the anti-trans
propaganda disseminated by vile
transphobes Like Yours Truly for example
here it is
hi kids there's no such thing as a boy
or a girl and I can prove it so gather
around the family or the parents
everybody answer my questions you either
say boys or girls who's usually taller
oh boys okay but you've met some short
boys right you met some tall girls so
usually boys are taller but not always
okay who likes the color pink
girls okay
um but you've met girls who don't like
pink and you met boys who do like pink
so usually girls like pink but not
always
everything you can think of that makes a
boy or makes a girl
is usually but not always
some of them are not even usually
where does that leave you
free you get to like what you like you
get to be who you are
maybe you're even like me and you're not
a boy or a girl
wow brilliant
I mean the great thing about this
argument is that I can use it to erase
literally anything from existence for
example most penguins are black and
white but some penguins are albino and
have all white feathers therefore
Penguins don't exist
the average length of a novel is 90 000
words but some novels are well over two
hundred thousand or even 500 000 words
therefore books don't exist here's an
interesting one the average IQ of a
human being is between 85 and 115.
the average IQ of a fruit bat is 2.3
Jeffrey Marsh's IQ is also 2.3 therefore
human beings don't exist or fruit bats
don't exist or Jeffrey Marsh is a fruit
bat or perhaps all these things are true
indeed we might as well say that fruit
bats don't exist and also Jeffrey Marsh
is a fruit bat considering that Jeffrey
Marsh is claiming that boys and girls
don't exist while also claiming that a
boy who identifies as a girl should be
accepted and affirmed as one
he demands that we affirm someone's
self-identity as something that
according to him doesn't exist
this remains one of the many many
self-contradictions and gender ideology
it holds it holds a sacrosanct an
individual's identification with or in a
particular sex category while at the
same time insisting that the sex
categories are mythological
there are no girls
and also that person over there with a
penis is one
you must accept him as something that is
nothing or else you have erased him even
though we're the ones who just erased
the entire category that he is claiming
membership in
there is no way to make sense of this
hopeless tangle of contradictions you
can't understand it because it is not
meant to be understood
Marsh justifies his Erasure of boys and
girls by pointing out that some girls
are taller than some boys and some boys
like the color pink
this is the left the level of
intellectual rigor that we get from the
left on this topic you probably don't
need me to explain why this reasoning is
flawed but I will anyway
um we speak about height and color
preference in terms of averages
okay in particular height anyway we talk
about averages and especially
um the existence of outliers within a
category
does not throw the existence of the
entire category into question on the
contrary you need the outliers in order
to come up with the average you cannot
have an average without the outliers
that's the whole point of the average
but the fact that we can come up with
averages Within These categories and
then compare the categories against each
other is a pretty good indication that
the categories exist
if we can say anything at all about a
category okay if we can make any
statements if we can offer any
descriptions of any kind
then that means the category exists
the very statement not all boys are tall
automatically validates and confirms the
existence of boys as a category because
you're talking about them if they didn't
exist the statement would be meaningless
it doesn't make any sense to speak
descriptively about a group of people
who according to you are fictional it
would be like if you wanted to prove
that leprechauns don't exist and so you
said you know not all leprechauns have
red hair some are blonde
okay so you're saying they do exist then
I mean you're describing them
so what we've learned here is that even
if you can only speak about a category
in terms of rough averages
that doesn't mean the category is
illegitimate or non-existent
but in the case of boys and girls men
and women we can actually speak much
more definitively March Clan March
claims that there's nothing we can say
about men or women that
would apply to every member of that
group and that's what's known as begging
the question okay not to be confused
with raising a question even though the
phrases are often used interchangeably
he is begging the question about sex
differences by embedding his conclusion
into the premise of his argument begging
the question he proves quote unquote
that men and women don't exist by
pointing out that there are no
definitive facts about them
but that argument could only even begin
to work if we assume from the outset
that it's true that there are no
definitive facts about them but it's not
true
I can say about men for example
that all of them are male
and all males are of the nature to
produce sperm and impregnate females
meanwhile all women are female and all
females are of the nature to produce OVA
and bear offspring
even the females who do not bear
offspring are still of the nature to do
so it is natural for them to do so they
are the only ones who can do so disease
or old age or genetic defect May prevent
them from doing so but that doesn't
change their nature the same in the
reverse is true for males
I can say that all human beings are of
the nature to walk on two legs it's
natural for us to walk on two legs a man
who loses a car and a leg in a car
accident or who's born deformed
still shares this nature
all humans are of the nature
to be self-aware and sentient conscious
this is one of the defining features of
human beings It Is What Makes Us human
and that doesn't change just because
some human beings are in a coma injury
or sickness has deprived Some Humans of
this natural function that doesn't mean
that it's not a natural function
in fact the man in a coma only confirms
that human beings are conscious because
we wouldn't be able to identify and
label unconsciousness if we weren't
conscious ourselves the exception proves
the rule this is true of unconsciousness
in human beings just as it's true of
infertility in women
in a similar way
if it wasn't natural for human beings to
possess basic intelligence and reasoning
skills I would not be able to identify
Jeffrey Marsh as being especially stupid
but human beings are supposed to have
basic reasoning and intelligence which
is how I know the Jeffrey Marsh's
bottomless stupidity is unusual
and possibly an indication of some sort
of brain disease or trauma
which is something that he should really
probably look into talking to his doctor
about
but in the meantime what I can say is
that he is canceled and that'll do it
for us for this portion of the show as
we move over to the members block hope
to see you there if not talk to you
tomorrow Godspeed
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]